thank you Peter delighted to be here at
Berkeley it's a great place to visit and
also share with you some of these things
that we've been doing it's good that
these talks are 4:00 p.m. so as you
leave hopefully some of this may be
useful to you on your trip home so you
hopefully won't so I should acknowledge
a number of people several students
postdocs people from places like Infosys
who worked with us and NUS colleagues
and also several organizations that
supported the initial pilots and also
adopted the solution subsequently
and also folks who helped the program by
their generous monetary donations so the
topic is urban in mobility and it looks
like this in an extreme sense it's
extreme from our point of view but it's
a everyday occurrence in Bangalore this
was in fact the starting point for me I
wasn't stuck in about traffic jam in
December 2007 in Bangalore somewhere
like that and then you look around to
see what's happening elsewhere this is
China and buses and this is the famous
Japanese the Shinjuku Station and the
the modes of transport are not really
relevant congestion is just liquid is
okay and peak-hour gets really bad but
some of them can last more than the peak
hour this is a nine day long traffic jam
in going from Beijing towards Inner
Mongolia and it's a 100 kilometer 60
mile long traffic jam okay
it's just nothing happened for nine days
people are stuck you know you can see
here people selling drinks and other
things too you know while you wait we're
clear in about three hours so it's a
very interesting phenomenon and there
are many things to do congestion that
I've become
while working on this things like
phantom waves and stuff that people have
looked at and documented but when you
sort of step back and out of it out of
one of those being one of these people
was frustrated too what is the cost of
congestion there's a the Texas
Transportation Institute puts out
numbers this is the extra amount of
money and fuel spent by way-cool stuck
in traffic so it's not the cost of
transportation the time and money spent
to get you from A to B this is just when
you're stuck add it up across major
areas in the US this is the number so as
these numbers grow there are estimates
but other cities and other countries are
in putting these numbers out and they're
somewhat similar very big if we could
make a dent in these sort of numbers by
that saving 10% is very meaningful
thinking this doesn't take into account
other bad things like emissions and
accidents here I don't mean safety just
in the sort of accidents loss of lemon
life I also mean every day many metros
people that are crowded people come in
and some of them like the London
Underground Delhi Metro the platform is
open to the tracks there is nothing
stopping you for example Hong Kong and
Singapore have barriers but in these
ones where it's open to the track the
danger is that you could fall into the
track because people keep coming behind
you
so sometimes trains wait in the tunnel
to let people who have been laid off
from the previous train exit the
platform before pulling in okay so lots
of precautions are taken and it just
asked sort of general slowness loss of
capacity so if you look at what's the
basic problem in these networks is not
difficult to say that sometimes
sometimes which are short or long demand
vastly excites exceeds supply
okay so it's difficult to build your way
out of this is difficult in this
situation occurred in computer networks
we not you know belonged and supply it's
very easy to drag wires or do other
things the cost in the transportation
world is significant it takes a lot of
money in a lot of space a lot of years
to do these things and so something must
be done about curbing demand okay and
our work is on the one hand consider
incentives pay people money to curb
demand so instead of charging people try
on the peak time pay people to travel
off-peak okay that's what we did that's
one form of our Gingin there's other
things we've done with similar ideas on
for wellness and recycling I'll come to
those during the course of the talk this
can coexist with penalties so you can
charge the peak time commuters and
reward the off-peak commuter and on the
other hand try to increase this with
more data and perhaps mobile apps that
is there's some supply and get demand
shifting not in time but in space or
other things like that okay you can
reach people that's that's the point of
those mobile apps so now engines are
getting into this what are they well the
main elements there are several things
this is from the Stanford program called
Capri congestion and parking relief
incentives this ran for two and a half
years was funded by the USDOT this is
for the commuters of Stanford University
to nudge them to travel off-peak both in
the morning time when the end of the
campus and the evening time when they
exit the campus okay Sanford could be a
potentially Berkeley it could be large
other employer like for example Google
or Facebook or anybody else that has a
large collection of people coming at
some you know within a small amount of
time in the morning and exiting in the
small window of time in the evening
causing congestion so cities and the
company might be interested incentive
programs like this so this is the
screenshot of an account I will come to
that later for now think of this as like
you know if you're a frequent flyer
miles program member we know let's take
as an example in internet lines this is
where you earn your miles and you go to
some website and monitor your record of
earned miles and trips made and then you
redeem your miles okay this is very
similar your behavior of times over
rival and departure are sensed as
appropriate you get points for making
sort of trips in the right time and you
get to monitor how many points you've
accrued so far what status you have so
this is bronze silver gold platinum how
many dollars you won and when was the
last trip you made and what to do and
this some other your friends are also
involved this is a fake account we
created for demo purposes this is
rewards this is money being given out by
the program it's a live ticker tape and
I will tell you how that works
and so there are some element there's
many things where I want to focus on
three main things first is the money we
paid out in the form of lottery so this
points that you accrued could either be
redeemed deterministically 100 points
equals $1 or you could use that to play
a game of chance and that is like a sort
of self administered lottery and the
game of chance led to some winnings okay
the second element is friends money in
other words incentivizes you to change
your behavior but also it's well known
in many programs that if you have
friends on the program and they do
something you have the effect of social
influence that's the second thing we
look at
a third thing we can look at is the
effect of personalized offers as you
exhibit your behavior so I learned that
you are more likely to travel off peak
on Tuesday and Thursday mornings we're
unlikely to do so on Monday Wednesday
Friday or some some evening times you
have more latitude then we will nudge
you for off-peak travel at those times
and it's personalized so different
people have different times that they
prefer the shift and different amount of
points that they might be needed you
know you might need to give them
different amount of points so that's
what this is personalized office these
are the main elements I will talk about
okay but this is an hour Gingin I really
okay with this just at a high level
because I'm going to dig into each one
of them so to begin with let's talk
about what is the reason for randomized
rewards what was the reason for paying
randomly okay so this is a well-known
example in most economics books chapter
one would be this the term loves game
your offer two envelopes one of them
below one has thousand dollars in it
just deterministic okay the second
envelope has hundred ten thousand
dollars and you can win this amount of
money with one percent chance and
otherwise you win nothing okay so the
expected value here is 1100 which one
would you choose okay so if I can just
get a quick show of hands who wants
$1000 on low okay who wants the second
envelope okay consistent I see you guys
are consistent okay so I've had a show
of hands from David and ever before the
consistent okay so the second version is
you know everything is the same that the
odds and stuff the ratios or numbers the
same but now it's like one dollar on the
one hand was $110 in the other hand
we're gonna just get a quick show of
hands is who wants all of one now
okay the ones on below too okay good so
if you looked around or if you've had a
sense for the question you know you kind
of see that lotteries make sense there's
some things you can prove about this
within the framework expected utility
theory but I'll summarize that are
saying and the stakes are low players
are more risk seeking so it makes sense
to consider lotteries as payment for
payment and the question is you know
there's an experiment now so what sort
of numbers are interesting and how to
make it work right
I wouldn't work okay
to give you an idea the Capri program
that we ran a Stanford we were looking
for ten off-peak trips five morning
trips by evening trips and we had one
dollar per computer per week to put into
the common pool of money from which they
would win and so each trip was $0.10
deterministic that would be envelope one
if you made an offbeat trip and for 10
cents it's hard to imagine people
shifting on the other hand the random
rewards side you could win dog you know
you played a game of chance it was
basically snakes and ladders and you
rolled a die for 10 points a roll and
this died so this piece made its way how
your piece made its way on the board I
landed on tiles that paying you you go
paint and the payments ranged from $1 to
$50 and the highest status you had the
higher amounts of money who stood to win
and the lower status was just you know
you meant 21 smaller amounts of money
and smaller average values as well okay
so that was it
no but before we got started on all this
we wanted to test the hypothesis the
random rewards indeed make a difference
or are attractive so I was teaching a
Freshman Seminar course in spring 2010
and we ran this recycling experiment in
the state of California you get five
cents for returning this bottle and ten
cents for the bigger version or it could
be a can
and the question is what if we took that
recyclable and offered the deterministic
value as well as random options these
are the sort of major denominations okay
all these are like denominations in
which we have currency but I didn't make
the expected payoff for this random
option higher than the deterministic
option often you do that because
otherwise why would someone take a risk
okay so but we just left it as five
cents on average and we got people and
so this is Freshman Seminar undergrads
dressed up in sort of cans
you know exercise it was pretty exciting
to work with them it probably was
because it was an undergrad seminar hard
to see in working in a grad seminar and
they lobbied people at Sproul hall
equivalent at Stanford white Plaza and
then we continued doing it for nine days
over a total of 18 hours at different
locations to just get more people to
participate and what happened was the
first version of this was offered like
this you came you had five recyclables
let's say that meant you had five goes
in this game of five trials and in this
case this person says I want to recycle
five cans or bottles and I want to try
each one for the $5 option so they could
win 0 or they could win $25 or some
multiple of 5 you know dollars right in
between and then a MATLAB program would
go and evaluate you know your chance of
winning so it would just sort of be this
sort of you know the time it took think
time for the program and then you either
want something or you didn't okay you
know people came and did this for the
first day and what do we find okay so
the most interesting thing we found just
because I was over all the booth was a
person came with recyclables and just
was texting they didn't care to know the
outcome of the game they didn't
participate in this they weren't the
random rewards his outcome but you could
have just advertised in the newspaper
like lotteries used to do ok lottery
numbers okay we could send him an email
so we wanted them to be more engaged
okay that's one thing we wanted to do
second thing is there's a problem here
of trust you know the odds are supposed
to be as declared but how does the
person the user or the player have proof
of this
okay so maybe sneaky Lina's system was
just not paying them and so second
version was we made a game and the $5
option we showed them a 10 by 10 tile
grid so you were supposed to win five
dollars with one in hundreds that is
five cents on average okay
so that's why it's a ten by ten tile
grid if you had chosen the $20 option
that would have been a one in four
hundred chance and that would be 20 by
20 title grid so the odds become very
obvious to you as a player this is
actually separately interesting because
there's this theory in economics called
prospect theory by Kahneman and torski
which has found empirically to
psychological experiments that humans
don't quite understand very small
probabilities just the biases okay
heuristics in our mind so this is just
something trying to make it explicit one
hundred dollars one in four hours what
is the difference what does it look like
so some people did go to the twenty
dollar office and found four hundred
tiles and then said I don't want this
this looks like you know not easy to win
so they went back to the other option
okay and so now you choose chose your
five tiles like this and then the system
said you didn't win by stealing the tile
behind which there was money okay
this was this happens people think that
that was exactly that happened so close
okay and I think it's just some mental
tick we have but this is this is
material okay and now what did we find
we found that they were engaged this is
a student who came with some number of
units
I think 70 or so chose the $20 option so
this is the there's our twenty by twenty
tile where it looked and they drew a
face with a smiley okay so this was sort
of an engaged user this immediately sort
of clueless into this is the way to do
it games have narrative so the persons
who were listed here one of them is
Coleman funk was also done or Stanford
he and two other folks who are the
inventors of Guitar Hero of the game
actually started seeing some of the
stuff that we did for the other things
and told us about how to think of
designing games that have levels have a
narrative so you know this is like a
scratch scratch or game it was kind of
the least interesting version okay but
then when we do the snakes and ladders
they had those comments to make and so
we learned some things okay there as
well
- in case you're wondering the way we
solved a mystery of like the system
cheating you I mean here it's still
possible after you made your choices the
system sneakily picked the green tile to
be different from yours pocketing the
money for itself well the the thing
would be if you were to literally go to
a boots and do this okay like in a
recycling it's what's called a reverse
vending machine the system can simply
print out its choice ahead of time
before you make your choices but you
can't see what it is is you can see that
it's printed on that paper over there
and that'll be shown to you afterwards
okay so the system can come it first
that's a way of verifying that it's not
cheating you okay so and then there's
the internet version of it okay so what
happened how did the recycle is decide
to recycle several units went for the
five cent option unexpectedly for us
meaning this was seemingly this is the
you know
zero-risk auction this is about right
so this insert a very Conrad sort of
utility function at the low payoff
regime what happened in fact was three
students came simultaneously and they
wanted to just recycle there they all
had roughly two hundred bottles each
recycled it with us we begged them to
take you to the facility in fact they
would have gone to the facility we said
we will enter your numbers and
everything but we don't have space in
our car to take this much stuff okay but
we offered something and they said no
your honor right so we did
okay we paid them money we collected the
recyclables etc okay so this is gives
you an idea of how random rewards help
okay I hope there's a more concrete
exploration of this with the Singapore
public transit program I will come to
now let me move to a second thing social
influence how are your friends influence
you and the two ways directly one is it
recruitment if a friend invites you it's
word-of-mouth marketing less expensive
but what we found also is that it's not
spam if your friend invites you in white
you spam okay just better to get your
friend to do the inviting secondly the
[Music]
people you go and try to do recruitment
of commuters in a large public transit
system unlike a Stanford there is no
mailing list you can't sort of say guys
we have a program please come so we
found subsequently Facebook is a good
mailing list seemingly now everybody
else has found out that that's the case
but you could we didn't do any
we just wanna advertise the program but
friends are good good for this too like
they will you know invite other
commuters so you don't even run the risk
of it's very well selected group okay
second is behavioral shift itself so on
the first one quickly some numbers we
launched the Singapore in sync program
in January 2012 with nine newspapers
you know in the major languages three to
two or three TV stations and radio show
etc we only have two thousand five
people signing out okay and then Chinese
New Year came and seemingly nobody's
heard of this program because you know
there's only so much you can get out in
one spot of marketing and so we just
didn't know what to do until we decided
to have not just invite your friend by
email but rather invite your Facebook
friend so we we made Facebook Connect
Google connect Yahoo etc just link Gmail
that's a time wait we link them okay on
February 14th Valentine's Day we said
recommend a friend sort of you know
program launched it rather immediately
we basically doubled in a in a further
month but the important number is this
how many of these people are now in the
system because of friends and you see
that growing
okay so this is sort of finding users
through their friends that's one thing
in this program which is step tacular
was a wellness program we did this is
not trying to get you to go to the gym
but rather to just get you to walk a few
more steps
so the Accenture USA have 33 offices in
this country and their participants
employees were participants in this
program and they got a pedometer which
they use to upload readings on to this
online portal that we created and then I
gave them points depending on how many
steps they walked and that led that led
them to redeeming options or the
deterministic of the random type okay so
the behavior is just walking more and
what you see here is when the program
launched the the average number steps
taken by participants is this blue line
this is across all participants the
program actually launched a month before
this I should say and initially we
didn't have any again friends option we
introduced that a month into the program
this is a truncated chart and people who
have friends in the program versus
people who don't have friends in the
program you have this sort of gap okay
that is those with friends in the
program have more likely to walk more
okay now this is sort of one time sort
of finding and then it's you know social
people more likely to walk more and
those sort of you know that ambiguity s
be taken out but we've seen this
consistently in other programs and I'll
share those with you there's one thing
second thing that happened as well as
this one which is the more friends you
had the more you tended to walk up to a
certain point the moment you had more
than six friends you this is across all
experiments we've seen this cement or
eat or you know xx friend has no effect
x-ray in fact on you know behavior
change the other thing we found was also
people who have friends in the program
ten or to complete the program with a
much higher chance and this one is more
interesting because it is the case that
some people lost a pedometer think
twenty eight people lost their
pedometers this is one of those things
were carry here and that means they just
you know not going to be in the program
anymore however some of them rejoined
the program when one of the friends
invited them to you know friend them on
the program we decided rejoin the
program okay so that was an example and
they even told us this by email but this
happened okay so that's the effect of
friends okay what I'll do now is to tell
you a little bit about how this all
worked came together and the capri
program is one where it all came
together we were only finished
developing the basic ingredients except
tackle happened before the
transportation projects as in the
recycling experiment so that's how it
came together in the Singapore project I
call in sink incentives for Singapore's
commuters and the goal was incentivize
of big travel
and we launched it as a six month
university trial with our colleagues in
NUS and then it was interesting and the
government one of the continued so
company called urban Angels was founded
with some of the students and myself
enough others and from July 2012 till
summer 2016
urban engines offered this program and
then we got bored by Google Maps in
summer 2016 and I will tell you the
results for this duration of time for
which I have analyzed the data so around
the time that we concluded was at least
400,000 plus registered participants as
well as companies so a company could
join the program for example you know
some bank or hospital and then the part
would be enriched for their community
for their commuters okay in addition to
whatever was the base you could get more
the summary finding is that the shift in
peak load is about 10% so the program
continues even now okay it's nice to
actually now called travel smart rewards
so how does it work it's exactly like a
frequent flyer program for public
transit users so you have the smart card
like we have in the Bay Area clipper
card it's how you pay for your public
transit system there's an equivalent
over there and you tap into a station do
you know the turnstile opens you board
and you tap out on the other side that
creates a commuting history which gives
us some number of kilometers of travel
and for every kilometer you took this
trip you know a wreckin AMA will give
you a point and if you trip post in the
off-peak time you've got three or more
points per kilometer depending on status
that's it that's the program very easy
to explain we actually found it very
easy to explain this after we said aha
just needed laches last is on to look
like a public trial like a airline miles
program everybody gets thought so the
biggest problem with these things that
we found is the ability to communicate
what you're trying to do to a very large
group of people with whom you're not
going to cut meet face to face
so it has to be something very simple
and raise you to understand ok this was
like the biggest challenge whether
responses to their emails or even some
personalized offers especially we had to
make them really clear so even you were
an instinct portal and you looked at
your history of points earned and
redeemed and rewards so the rewards
could be cash and that whatever you want
went back in your travel card or a
Stanford Rio and gave away tickets to
the Rose Bowl game that in the Andrew
Luck days we were that was a you know
this is time for Berkeley said I want to
make a big deal out of it but we will be
able to fixture for a couple of years
and so the monetary value of this ticket
is $75 but because of the scarcity this
was like go last okay we had tremendous
you know we we had people you know how
Rose Bowl works is that you you play
until a little mid-december and then you
qualify around mid-december for the game
at the end of the similarly January and
so you really have a very short window
and mostly when the university is closed
so we had about five days to get people
to invite their friends like a
recruitment drive for ten tickets what
the total of sounds somewhat sound $50
which we gave us five pairs people
invited their friends and they're a
seventeen percent boost in enrollment it
was amazing okay so the city wants to
consider doing this just go to your
local sports teams they will those
tickets are water a lot and they will be
happily potentially happily happy to do
it because it's in the public interest
so this is the program and
you're going to see a series of charts
and numbers but they'll what what what
what are they so this is the morning
5:00 a.m. time and noon and this is the
peak hour so it's 7:30 to 8:30 is the
peak are so follow the blue line this is
what people were doing in the three
months as revealed by the travel card
this is the trips that they were making
in the three months preceding joining
the program all we wanted to know was
what time did that trip start what was
the distance of the trip
okay and so this says what time do the
trips start the blue line so you can see
the most of the peak times are like
between 7:30 and 8:30 and the orange
line is what happened afterwards after
joining the program so in this case this
is everything done as a percentage show
the shift is seven and a half percent
off of the peak as shown here now this
is for people who might have been
already commuting off-peak so it was
every every every every person who
signed up okay this picture is people
who traveled a little bit more in the
peak time before they joined so they
made five peak trips at least in the
three months before the joinder is 60
week days of commuting then they were in
this category so this is software User's
you know this is a subset of these users
and this is further subsets these people
made at least ten peak trips and these
people made at least 20 peak trips okay
yes well it's there you know this
plotted is a five-minute Bin's is
visible if you sort of break it down
more finally this this set of people are
sort of committed peak time travelers
they seem to just shift just essentially
slightly before and there's a it's
almost invisible in the 5-minute level
that
plotted this data here the the last two
is less visible by the way I should say
here here is less visible but there it
is definitely visible in fact you can
see this orange thing is hesitating a
little bit before it you know the
flatness before that is visible that's
right
true yeah that's true and I agree with
you in fact this this became a little
bit of so there's something else going
on look at these guys okay so someone
traveling here 6:15 decides to they're
not even in the peak obviously but they
like the you only got the extra three
you know extra points if you travel
between 6:30 and 7:30 or eight thirty
nine thirty that's the shoulder hour so
everywhere else you got just one
kilometre equals a point in what's
orange here the orange zones is where
you are one kilometer equals three
points or four points or whatever okay
so if you're traveling at 6:15 and you
took a ten kilometer trip you'll get ten
points but if you shift it to just after
6:00 6:30 that now is going to give you
30 points
so it's an unintended bump here okay
that these people were already going off
big they just decided get that bump okay
so this is an example of how things work
okay so the moral story here is that the
more peak time trips you're making
before you join the more likely you are
the more you have to shift out off the
peak and that's what this is showing you
can also break it down by many things
those who have friends those who don't
have friends in the program those who
play that random game those who just
trade for fixed exchange rates short
distance long distance whereas other
ways okay it's analyzing but a paper and
a student thesis now this is for the
first six months whereas if you look at
a longer period of time this is all
participants or a long period of time
versus those who were traveling in the
so the ones who traveling at least five
trips and the peak and so on okay so
this is how things the same charts
analyzed from the end of 2012 onwards
okay now this is a thing that shows how
people with friends did
so those who have no friends versus
those who have just one friend in the
program two and so on so you can see
then the more friends you have the
better off you know you know you are in
terms of shifting out of the peak okay
I'll end with one last thing about this
so you know it's well known in the case
of airline miles programs that you know
if you're part of a miles program you
tend to you know the year before and the
year after joining miles program you
have usually more miles that of travel
just something someone is monitoring
than rewarding you for it could that be
true or is that true it's public transit
adoption improved or increased on
account of you joining it joins program
that would be interesting and good
benefit this is number of weekday
morning trips week on a weekly basis
in the ten weeks preceding you're
joining the program to the day the week
you joined and subsequently the average
number of trips that someone made who
didn't join the program made about close
to one and a half morning peak trips and
that jumps to about two and a half
morning peak trips so you know two on
five so 40% jump okay so that's a pretty
you know interesting useful uptick this
is for people who had been in the
program much longer this is not you know
people the steady-state that's how many
big trips of the morning pictures they
make so this is an example of someone
who typically joins here and then sort
of just climbs and hopefully over there
you know long into the future they'll
join this red line so this is sort of
good in terms of making the public
transit most sticky okay so that's I'll
stop there with this go to the next
topic on how data could be used I was
hoping to show other things on like you
know there's very interesting things one
can do about understanding how Road
usage happens and how to shift traffic
and but also in public transit so one
example is apps like Waze are known to
do this but at the same time more
centralized and systematic
undertaken you can see how that works in
public in the case of public transit but
I don't have the data anymore
so I'll share with you a New York City
Taxi Dana okay but underlying all this
is a system we built not different from
the kind of big data systems that we see
people building either in the real world
or and seus programs etc system see
effort and we didn't have Arobin engines
and our data was the GPS traces or
package scans so whether you're tracking
people's movements or package movements
awake of movements they all sort of have
some signatures that they leave on a map
as they move some bread crumbs of bread
crumb equivalents and so city bus
packaged in a truck or a taxi okay so
all these things are just signals that
are collected and going to this thing in
the cloud and where most of what really
consists of healing the data so it's not
easy to snap all this to Street there
are lots of gaps Durban Canyon type
effects so you have to fill it in and
snap it to Street and do various things
like this the challenge is really that
you have like lots and lots of Wiggles
putting this out think of a system like
lyft or uber where there are a few
thousand vehicles or the taxi system in
New York has 26 13,000 taxis there's a
lot of data coming out rapidly and other
systems that was very interesting and
challenging so what we did was built the
first module called digital replica this
is showing you the buses and Singapore
and the redder it is and and the fatter
it is the more clear it is in the screen
currently how many commuters are there
how many buses are there so as you zoom
into the screen this would have gone
down and the soul of this gone run where
you see more detail and this is what's
happening at 8:02 a.m. on a certain day
okay so it really is this view okay and
the interesting thing was at the time
that this was done it was not easy to
put more than thousand moving dots on a
map d3 the visualization you know thing
at the time had a limit
so working around that etc was
interesting and pushing it through like
a Wi-Fi access you know a laptop or
tablet was interesting challenging
questions but you can answer questions
like for the user
eventually which stations are crowded
right now or show me all the slow moving
overcrowded buses okay and so you could
sort of just blot out the rest of it and
just look at that stuff okay that's an
example or something in do that's why
it's called a digital replica you can
sort of get this view from about 10 to
30,000 feet about in the air and look at
it as if you x-ray eyes down the subway
tracks and so on okay the other thing
you can do is this so-called database
movement database and you looked at it
over a certain amount of time over let's
say this quarter of you know like let's
say the spring quarter of collecting
this data I want to know this is an
example chart here which says I want to
know in lower Manhattan what was the
speed of taxis in the very early morning
hours which is a red line versus the
peak hour what's the difference okay
broken down by the neighborhoods so this
this sort of thing requires you to take
the map and put this geospatial data you
can impose off the neighborhood's or zip
codes and so on you can superimpose then
break your data down by that that's the
sort of effort that this is okay but you
can answer this but equally you can also
answer questions about the vehicles
themselves if you have the data for
example how many small fragile packages
from some customer were broken during
shipping the sort of thing you can do
okay or harder the new one-way roads
reduce traffic congestion in the central
business district okay this is where our
urban planning folks the transportation
planning folks wanna know okay so that's
how you could use these things now let
me show you in the next five minutes
some sort of what came out of this okay
what I also used this platform as part
of a course I taught so I'll tell you
before I jump into
a few things I'm going to show you what
are the set of things that one can do
and what our city's interested in
knowing the answers to sometimes right
so students look looked at things like
because we have New York City Taxi data
is every time you enter a taxi that is
its it's now hired to the time you were
let off where did you enter and what
time and where did you exit in what time
that's the trip and what was the fare
paid and this is only for payments made
through credit cards cash payments were
available record of course is not
available and how much did you tip okay
you if you've been in New York City you
know sort of pick a number or you know
enter your number
okay whatever number you wanted to what
percentage of the bill that's the data
now you could use this and students
looked at the UN General Assembly meets
in September and what happens to traffic
around where the UN building is and how
does they shift and get diverted as seen
by the taxis these taxis are sort of
this ubiquitous sensors you know you can
see how they get a sense for the general
background traffic and secondly what
happens during US Open everybody must
know okay where do people come from what
hotels do they go back to how many other
visitors how many locals taxis give you
a fairly good idea same thing for
concerts for example what happens during
the northeaster blizzard okay
how long will sitting down how long it
take to come back up things like this
okay
much of this isn't a thesis of a student
who studied this data as well as some
class project including like you know
wage-earning and differences in how
people how taxi drivers were disposed to
giving rights to some neighborhoods
versus not things like that so there's
something else that is true almost all
human movement in large met Rosa is
highly periodic so this is one example
of it and no matter how you what level
you break it down this is picking a
neighborhood pick up from midtown
Manhattan
Mondays Tuesdays Wednesdays Thursdays
Fridays Saturdays and Sundays so if you
look at the weekdays the measured in the
thousands over a 24-hour period because
this is zero hours and 24 hours it's
periodic fairly consistently you know
across the Mondays I'll talk about some
exceptions okay and here are Tuesday's
and so on and most weekdays looks
similar to each other of course within
the particular day Fridays look more
similar to each other than two Mondays
weekends look different now these are
the Memorial Day holidays in a month so
they look different but if you go to
financial district the figure is
different okay but that's the conclusion
the same you know it is in other words
that the numbers here are different and
as is the pattern but again it looks
highly periodic basically in fact the
sphere sees even more pronounced if you
zoom into the peak hour
not just for taxis for bus systems for
trains for everything it's just one of
the same people going from the same
place to same other place to work and
whatever else is governing our everyday
behavior Brooklyn implication is that
human movement is highly periodic this
could be used for recognizing patterns
and provisioning supply accordingly so
if you know that X number of people are
expected to go from here there and a
given day you make arrangements you
could make arrangements accordingly it's
even better than this like the Moscone
Center here you know has large events
10,000 or 15,000 sometimes people are
very large numbers accumulate there for
conferences depending on how many people
were dropped there in the morning and
you know you could look at the evening
and see how many you know you have a
rough estimate how many people have been
require rights to go back out we had
really that for the Jacob Javits Center
in New York as well as for you know the
next topic I'm going to talk about
Madison Square Garden Knicks games
roughly you know you have an estimate
okay so you have a this is called latent
demand its demand that you know exists
that's going to exert itself on the
system
okay yeah all right so then I want to
end on a sort of something funny or I
hope it is funny we had this question do
fans tip taxi drivers more if the local
team the New York Knicks win then when
they lose okay so you're gonna now the
question on your minds is causation
versus correlation wait until I get
through okay so what would you do well
we go to the map of New York put a
perimeter around Madison Square Garden
and say pick ups or drop offs before the
game and pick ups after the game you
know the game time within 50 meters or
this place look at all the pickups
that's what you would do that's what the
system can do for us
then we look at days when there were
games days when there were no games
gaint days when the next one and days
when the Knicks lost okay and if you run
unpaired t-test with a p-value which is
sufficiently small meaning statistically
now is significant when the Knicks won
versus when the Knicks lost there's one
percent here difference close to one
percent which if you normalize 19 to
100% then it's actually a five percent
difference in the tip now you'll be like
well is this true is this like an
artifact well let's see okay I mean
statistically significance is high so
you would have to believe that it's true
that people do tip more but now there's
a nice thing about data you can do
better than that
as Changwon did he looked at the
distribution of tips what percentage
were people tipping as I said in New
York City you enter and you swipe your
car at the end of your trip in a taxi
the default tipping option is 20% they
just expect you to be justly generous
okay now you to show your extra pleasure
or lack thereof have to physically
choose the other options so in the next
one
Nick's lost is the red thing and next
one is the green thing like sort of
bluish green there's a bump out there 25
and 30 percent choices so this is okay
so people are just really choosing those
options and there's also a small bump on
the other side on the days that Nick's
won so general hypothesize the losing
team fans of the losing team don't like
this but honey he fought now this sort
of system you see are they going to the
unions you know so what is that Penn
Station of one of the stations like exit
you know in other words are they the
fans for the losing for the other side
maybe they're gonna be Airport over to a
hotel or where are they going after day
after where they you know where the taxi
leaves them right
are they going to residential area walk
so he was able to follow up on that so
that's the sort of thing you can do with
these systems again as I said this is
for just joined on a hopefully amusing
note but the questions are serious and I
hope you're both encouraged and
interested in this sort of thing and
this can be done for many thing many
problems that we have every day and
broadly gather and this topic of
societal networks transportation is one
an energy grid it could be water
conservation could be anything else so
with that I'll stop and thank you for
listening
[Applause]
yeah we did how big was the reward
versus how does the shift their paper
summarizing or TC summarizing that
because the highest reward at Stanford
of $50 and at a certain time in
Singapore is 200 there was increased to
400